[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente en france24
una semana más el programa llega a
producido desde casa como medida de
prevención por la situación de la
pandemia de kobe 19 en bogotá donde se
encuentra la sede de france 24 en
español esta semana comenzamos con una
buena noticia para los animales y sus
defensores colombia se convirtió el 12
de agosto en el primer país sudamericano
en prohibir las pruebas en animales para
productos cosméticos de cualquier tipo
la ley que no entra en vigor hasta
dentro de cuatro años veta cualquier
experimentación importación y
exportación fabricación y
comercialización de productos o de sus
ingredientes que sean objetos de pruebas
en animales colombia se suma así a una
lista de tan sólo 40 países con leyes al
respecto es un pequeño paso hacia el
bienestar animal que sufre en diversos
sectores de la producción del mundo de
hecho en datos de 2015 más de 190
millones de animales fueron usados ese
año en experimentos científicos fuera
del sector cosmético en la unión
europea' murieron 23 millones y medio de
animales en estas
que son hechas incluso en perros y monos
según la organización libre de crueldad
internacional que busca la prohibición
de cualquier experimento en animales el
90% de los medicamentos probados en
animales con resultados positivos no son
efectivos en humanos hablamos con la
líder de relaciones públicas para
norteamérica de esta organización quien
felicitó a colombia por esta decisión y
también nos habló sobre algunos ejemplos
de las pruebas que sufren los animales
en la industria cosmética más mal
estábamos las pruebas de cosméticos en
animales han existido desde hace mucho
tiempo y son textos muy anticuados que
desafortunadamente se siguen haciendo en
algunas situaciones un ejemplo de esto
sería inmovilizar a los conejos y
echarles directamente el ingrediente que
se está probando en los ojos para ver
cuál es la reacción o afeitarle todo el
pelo a un conejillo de indias y frotar
una crema en la piel para ver cómo
reacciona sin embargo estas pruebas se
pueden sustituir con alternativas no
animales que además suelen ser mucho más
similares a cómo sería la reacción en
humanos de todos modos
normalmente las alternativas son más
rápidas se consiguen los resultados más
tempranos que con los tests en animales
y son más precisas además cada vez
tienen un costo más similar de hecho a
veces son más baratas dependiendo de la
prueba así que existen muchos incentivos
para utilizar las alternativas donde
estén disponibles
y precisamente sobre estas alternativas
mónica en de brett son resaltó una parte
de la reciente legislación colombiana
que podría ayudar a que esta prohibición
se amplíe a otras industrias fuera de
los productos de belleza en el país y
que también podría beneficiar a otras
naciones de la región como las que
forman parte de la alianza del pacífico
que son méxico chile y perú
en las pruebas en animales se llevan a
cabo en muchos sectores productos de
limpieza para el hogar químicos
agrícolas en farmacéuticos medicamentos
está en todas partes
lo bueno de la ley que se aprobó en
colombia es que incluye el requisito de
invertir en buscar alternativas y esas
alternativas no sólo son válidas para
los cosméticos sino que estos productos
que fueron desarrollados por la presión
ejercida sobre los cosméticos se pueden
utilizar en otras industrias también así
que fue un muy buen paso para colombia y
una medida con buena previsión de futuro
para seguir buscando alternativas y
mejores pruebas que no usen animales
nuestra invitada resaltó el poder de los
consumidores para que se tomen este tipo
de decisiones a nivel global y nos
invitó a todos a buscar este luego en
los productos de belleza que compremos a
partir de ahora que certifica que no se
han hecho experimentos en animales ya
que cuanta mayor presión haya por
de los usuarios de cosméticos mayores
son las probabilidades de que los países
o la industria decidan prohibir este
tipo de prácticas cambiamos de tema y
pasamos a hablar ahora de los incendios
que están de nuevo calcinando cientos de
miles de hectáreas en la costa oeste de
eeuu este año el fuego además está
llegando a zonas que normalmente no son
tan secas como los bosques de secuoyas
del norte del estado la ola de calor en
agosto que llegó tras un año más seco de
lo habitual y que desencadenó tormentas
eléctricas en la región fue el
ingrediente perfecto para que estos
nuevos incendios se desarrollaran hay
más detalles de por qué se repiten estos
incendios en el informe que preparo
valentina torre sánchez de acuerdo con
expertos encender un fuego realmente no
es tarea difícil basta con material seco
una chispa y oxígeno
año tras año california se enfrenta a
voraces conflagraciones y en parte esto
se debe a que la vegetación californiana
toma la mayor parte de su humedad en
otoño e invierno pero luego sufre un
lento proceso de secado
convierte en material para que se
encienda el fuego
otro factor clave en las miles de
conflagraciones que enfrenta el estado
anualmente es la mano humana esto se une
a las altas temperaturas de la primavera
y el verano los fuertes vientos y las
tormentas eléctricas cada vez más
comunes a causa del cambio climático
precisamente ese fenómeno también ha
llevado a que en estaciones como el
otoño de 2019 no lloviera lo que provocó
incendios en otra época del año de igual
forma el cambio climático ha hecho que
en muchas ocasiones las corrientes que
definen el clima diario se desaceleren
lo que hace que el clima no cambie y el
calor permanezca en lo que se considera
popularmente como veranos prolongados un
estudio realizado por expertos de la
universidad de columbia señala que
mientras que en 1972 el área promedio
que afectaba en los juegos era de 611
kilómetros cuadrados al año en 2019 la
cifra llegó a los tres mil seiscientos
diez kilómetros cuadrados
es todo por esta semana sigan con más
medio ambiente en france24 punto com
[Música]